For the most part, it’s pretty good being
alive.
There are tacos, videos of monkeys, cheap
air travel and many exciting hats to choose
from.
But it all flashes by very quickly and you
barely get a moment to enjoy it between; sleeping,
school, work, waiting for Windows 10 to install,
and torrenting Star Wars.
And before you know it, it’s all over and
you’re floating away from your body wondering
what you could have achieved if you’d skipped
season 6 of How I Met Your Mother and gone
out to sit in the sunshine for a while.
So how do we hold on longer?
Can we avoid the inevitable end because we
are just not ready yet?
I mean come on, I’ve got tickets to Cirque
Du Soleil next week and I just bought a 3
for 1 toothpaste deal.
Can humans delay death?
Because, in the words of the great Terry Pratchett,
“inside every old person is a young person
wondering what happened.”
If you switch on the news for a few minutes,
you might feel like there is death and destruction
lurking around every corner and that you’ll
be lucky to make it to lunch time.
But the truth is, overall, we are living longer
than ever.
If you look back to 200 years ago, life expectancy
in almost every country except the UK was
below 40 and as low as 25 in some of Africa
and Asia.
Since then it has increased with strange regularity.
On average, we have gained one year of lifespan
for every five years that have passed.
There were obviously some dips after the world
wars, as well as the Spanish flu epidemic
in the early 20th century, but we have arrived
today at a global average of 71 years.
Women outlive men by about 4 to 5 years but
we’re still not sure why this is.
If it was down to less manual work, you’d
have expected there to be less of a difference
now that we all sit on bean bags, staring
into spreadsheets for 8 hours a day, but it’s
unchanged.
And if it’s the extra cigarettes, beer and
chicken wings men supposedly consume, then
why does the same difference occur in apes?
A Korean scientist named Han-Nam Park has
suggested it could be the effects of testosterone,
citing a study that showed eunuchs, that’s
men who have had their testicles removed,
lived noticeably longer than other men.
Um…
I think I’m fine with the five-year difference
actually.
It’s diet and medicine that keep pushing
our life expectancy up.
Although there must be some upper limit to
how long a human can live, there have been
no signs that we have reached it yet.
We will eventually arrive at a 100-year average
and probably keep going.
Soon we’re going to get pretty bored of
the sight of each other.
Heart disease and strokes are by far our biggest
killers but as the treatments and care for
these improve, we are getting better at fighting
them.
Both are linked to high blood pressure and
high cholesterol, so doctors can help patients
with a range of lifestyle changes and medications
to lower their risk.
Just 100 years ago, these killers were a lot
less common, not because people were leading
healthier lives; far from it, statistics show
we actually eat healthier now, even with the
prevalence of fast food.
But it was that people were dying much earlier
from infectious diseases such as pneumonia,
flu and tuberculosis.
Now that’s what happens when your national
cures are mainly whiskey, cigarettes, sea
air and radium.
They weren’t glowing with health, they were
just pumped full of radiation.
Aside from combatting disease, we have spent
many years looking into slowing the aging
process itself.
We’re not clear on exactly why we age but
a fairly common theory is that over time your
DNA loses its ability to withstand damage
and to repair itself, making mutations more
likely.
And these aren’t the cool mutations that
give you laser eyes and teleportation, these
are just your cells ceasing to function in
the way you need them to.
Your body renews almost perfectly between
the ages of about 20 to 35, and after that
your cells begin to lose interest and start
thinking about retiring, maybe to go sit by
a nice beach somewhere down by your kidneys.
So one way to combat this is to poke around
in the DNA and find the troublemakers.
The Buck Institute 238 genes that could be
deleted and increase the lifespan of yeast.
And you might be thinking; Oh yeast, whoopty-doo,
I always wanted immortal bread, but your DNA
shares much more in common with a slice of
toast than you might think.
That’s right, when you eat your lovely buttery
toast in the morning, you’re chomping down
on your DNA cousin, you monster!
They managed to get a massive 60% increase
in the life of these yeast strains and are
now looking to test this out a little higher
up the evolutionary chain.
The key gene for this 60% jump is called LOS1,
which is linked to a master switch that is
associated with calorie restriction.
It’s long been thought that calorie restriction
has been linked with longer lives.
After all, humans aren’t designed to gorge
ourselves every day on burgers and ever so
deliciously flaky, creamy, melt-in-your-mouth
pastries, yes, I know it’s difficult.
But humans are hunter gatherers at heart,
our body has evolved to go days without eating
at all, which was common for our prehistoric
ancestors.
Interestingly, during the Irish Potato Famine,
national life expectancy actually rose from
40 years to 50, going against every expectation.
Now, before you spit out your ramen and throw
away your banana, you’re not supposed to
starve yourself.
Malnutrition has a terrible impact on your
body.
The key is to walk that fine line of getting
just the calories you need to survive.
The research is still a little vague, partly
because no matter how dedicated you are, it’s
hard to get someone to have that much self-control
for 10 years or so.
I mean, I’ve only just mentioned food and
you’re already thinking about what’s in
your fridge; yes, that tub of Ben & Jerry’s
will still be there when this video’s finished,
please sit back down.
Experiments on mice that involve just limiting
their food on alternative days, known as intermittent
fasting, has resulted in longer living mice
and a reduction in age-related diseases such
as Alzheimer's, diabetes and cancer.
All from just missing a few meals each week.
It could work for a few reasons.
The reduced energy in your body may mean your
core temperature is slightly lower so your
general metabolism happens a little slower
too.
Also, less cellular division means there is
less chance for your DNA to become damaged.
So if you don’t want to eat less, maybe
just reduce your core heat by sitting in a
bath full of frozen peas and ice cream.
I should be a doctor.
The metabolism is clearly a big part of the
aging issue.
Researchers at Cardiff University were investigating
type 2 diabetes and they noticed that patients
who took the drug metformin lived, on average,
15 percent longer than a group of healthy
people who didn’t have diabetes and weren’t
taking metformin but were similar in nearly
all other respects, in terms of age, lifestyle,
favourite Game of Thrones character and so
on.
This is very surprising because diabetes,
even when controlled, should shorten your
lifespan.
It could be because metformin interferes with
a process called glycation.
This is a major metabolic process where sugars
attach to proteins but it leaves behind a
thing called Advanced Glycation Endproducts,
or AGEs ironically.
This is bad and they basically gum up your
biomolecular workings like when you got cake
in your keyboard.
Because we are a greedy and ridiculous species,
we’ve actual been adding AGEs to our food,
typically things with caramelization like
donuts, barbequed meat and dark sugared drinks.
Why does evil have to be so delicious?
Our last way of living longer sounds like
it’s been ripped from the pages of some
creepy Victorian novel.
In 2005, Thomas Rando from Stanford University,
found that he could rejuvenate older mice
by surgically linking their blood flow to
younger mice.
It apparently works best if there is a new
moon, the young mouse is a virgin and stays
off garlic-flavoured mouse food.
But maybe I’ve been reading too many cheesy
vampire novels.
This vampiric practise enabled the stem cells
of doddering old rodents to suddenly become
effective again and begin to repair damaged
cells, build new tissue and stop them being
so confused about smart phones.
Harvard University biologist Amy Wagers looked
into this further and believes it is a protein
called GDF11 that is responsible and that
this is what is lost in older mice.
She managed to get similar results to Rando
by just injecting them with the protein, but
Rando said that his creepy vampire way was
much more fun and gave him an excuse to wear
a cape and play My Chemical Romance at full
volume all day.
However, because this is science, recently
a team from Cambridge, Massachusetts claimed
that GDF11 actually increases with age and
acts to inhibit muscle generation.
So, the complete opposite.
See, this is why everyone hates you science,
stop contradicting yourself!
But before you start worrying about adding
a few years to the end of your days, you’re
probably better off dealing with the life
you have now.
So, go ask out that boy or girl you like,
find a good book to read and if you’re worried
that eating that box of donuts will shave
a week off your existence, why don’t you
compromise by leaving that bit in the middle,
that’s where all the calories are
you know.